Indiana police have released new clues
about a killer they believe is hiding in
plain sight
teenagers Abigail Williams and Liberty
German disappeared in February 2017
after going for a hike by an abandoned
rail bridge near Delphi Indiana I
remember this case well I drew a lot of
national attention when their bodies
were discovered a day later now
investigators are releasing this sketch
of a man who they believe murdered the
girls along with cell phone video and
audio of the suspect Don Dahler has been
following the story since the beginning
and is here with new details Don good
morning I can't believe they've never
solved this I know they've been so
frustrated out there Indiana State
Police say the new sketch of the suspect
was produced thanks to new information
and intelligence collected during the
investigation the head of the State
Police became emotional during a press
conference as he addressed the killer
whom authorities believe could still be
living among them holy a coward would do
such a thing
Indiana State Police Superintendent Doug
Carter did not hide his contempt for the
man they've been hunting for more than
26 months what will those closest to you
think of when they find out that you
brutally murdered two little girls
German and Williams were last seen
hiking near an abandoned rail bridge on
February 13 2017 their bodies were found
the next day in a wooded area about a
quarter mile away police initially
released a still image of the suspect
yesterday they revealed it was taken
from this video which was recovered from
the phone of Libby German watch the
mannerisms as he walks do you recognize
the mannerisms as being someone that you
might know German also recorded the
voice of the alleged killer and police
released an additional portion of that
audio after two years and thousands of
leads with no arrests police say they've
switched to a new investigative strategy
but wouldn't reveal the details
Libby Germans mother Carrie told our
Indianapolis affiliate WT TV she
welcomed a new direction
I'm so very appreciative
of the work that they're doing and the
Dylan their diligence and trying to
solve this case please keep it up don't
give up the head of the State Police
made this promise to the victims
families we will not stop
police have not revealed how the girls
were killed they do believe the killer
is from Delphi or has lived there before
and possibly even works there they also
think the suspect is between the ages of
18 and 40 but might appear younger than
his actual age they're right police know
that somebody knows something it's got
to be comforting to the parents to see
they're not giving up and I just think
as a parent when you have two of them
together you think that gives you some
degree of safety because - how could one
person get go to Franco at the same time
and it's such a small community you
would think someone would recognize this
person she's filming him for a reason -
Don so there's people will know the guy
by the way he walks I hope you hope
different it seems like the police know
more than they're saying exactly they
usually do yeah yeah but they said in
the news conference that person could be
in this room which makes me think - John
they know much more than they're saying
all right well hopefully we'll see you
back soon yeah